don't you wish xbox had a netflix
service for games something bigger than
just EA titles with EA access well that
wish is about to be granted I'm Tony
this is a game spot news update and for
all the latest from Microsoft be sure to
subscribe it's called Xbox game pass and
it's coming to Xbox one later this
spring for ten bucks a month you get
unlimited access to a wide selection of
games halo 5 payday 2 and NBA 2k16 are
among the first titles being offered and
microsoft says the catalog will be
updated every month as old titles are
removed to make way for different games
these will download straight to your
console and if you want to keep them
beyond the one month period you can
purchase the game for twenty percent off
plus any DLC at ten percent off seems
like a pretty sweet deal Phil Spencer
says the Xbox game pass is a strong lead
up to project Scorpio a souped-up new
console coming from Microsoft this
holiday in other console news the
Nintendo switch is about to launch for
everyone and if you want a bit more info
before you pick one up check out our
live stream that dives into the OS and
early zelda impressions for all the
latest on all the consoles you're
already in the right place